[Music]
it's something of a cliche to say this
but we live in a knowledge economy
increasingly people's a person's ability
to command the high wage is going to
depend upon having some skills having
skills that relate to
perhaps technology it doesn't always
have to be technology but it has to be
some kind of value add that you provide
that allows you to command some pricing
power in the labor market how you do
that is going to vary from industry to
industry in some cases it will be doing
things that computers do well a data
analyst for example in some cases it
will be doing things that computers
can't do human touch professionals a
nursing and things like that but
whatever it is you're going to have to
focus very hard on those skills and the
only way you can get those skills it's
through learning and through continuous
learning and any company trying to
hiring people will recognize that
probably the trait they're looking for
most is not a particular set of skills
but the the demonstrated ability to
acquire skills because any company will
realize I think that what's crucial is
not the particular set of skills you
have but that you demonstrate a capacity
to acquire them now because a few years
from now a few months from now it might
turn out that you have to acquire new
ones look at software programmers for
example any software programmer knows
that within 2 or 3 years almost
everything they're doing right now will
be obsolete and they will have to learn
a whole new language as it were
depending on whether you're doing
talking about mobile whether you're
talking about apps whether you're
talking about traditional computers and
of course depending on with the
particular configuration of hardware and
software you are using so all that keeps
changing in many many worlds and I think
that because of it the information
revolution it's going to happen even
more so in worlds that we don't usually
think of changing
accreditation in some way are the holy
grail of education the reason that
American universities are able to charge
the extraordinary price they charge is
because employers around the world
believe that this is the single best
sorting mechanism they have to figure
out whom to hire so that if you have a
undergraduate degree from Harvard or
Wawro or University of Pennsylvania's
Wharton School a bank is particularly if
it's in majoring in economics a bank is
going to think of the 20,000
applications we get for our entry 300
positions these are some very good
filters we look at the people who went
to Harvard and Wharton and Stanford and
things like that if you're looking for
people who are software programmers if
they have gone to a good computer
science program at a good university you
assume that's a very good way to filter
down and then you probably go through
interviews and things like that
what if somebody came to a technology
company or a bank and said look I don't
have the degree that you're looking for
but I did take 25 courses online from
these five online
Quorra you know MOOCs many of which are
stanford courses and harvard courses and
MIT courses and here's what i how i did
and here is a piece of paper that pieces
of paper that prove that demonstrate
that i finished those courses the grades
i got on them etc if employers start
treating those pieces of paper those
accreditations as worth a lot that
completely changes the nature of
education because then you are not you
know what you are being paid for is
really more outcome related it is
related to what skills have you acquired
rather than process related did you go
to a four-year bricks-and-mortar college
and live in the dorms with other people
some people may still value that latter
one and by the way it may still be worth
worthwhile for some people to pay that
because of the network effect because of
the people you meet at a harvard or yale
but you can
imagine that that would not be true at
universities one tear down or certainly
two tears down and in any case it would
place huge pressure on the pricing model
because all of a sudden people are able
to access many of the skills that that
you're being taught in top universities
at a fraction of the price so the key
here is whether the employers begin to
view accreditation as an outcome-based
process on skills as opposed to a a you
know a kind of a process in which it's
very important that you have spent the
four years at the college and and
acquired the full rounded education that
that college provides
you